N
FE
PUTIN'S RTNCEDASETIN, REAL ESTA.
FR IY TAKING ACTION,E OLIG'S
DOCKN .
>>HI D
JOHN.
L TA
ILL-GOTTEN.
EXPERTS IN MONEY LND
NATIONAL SECURITY, TASKS
ENFOARGET RUSSIA'S
TYCOONS.
>> WE'RE JOINING
APARENJETS.ZE LU SCHUR
>>E GRIP TIGHTENING AROUNDAIN.
THE STOCMACLOSED AGAIN TODAY.
CRATERING.
IT'S WORTH PENNY.
THEY C ME MONEY
SANC FROZEE
AND 'S BILLIONAIRES NTROL 30% O
WE CAN CONFIRM THE YACHT SEIZE
OLIGARCHS SPENT THA
MAG RTUNES AND PUTTING
F L ORR E THEMSELVES
AND NOW ANUNL  FOOTBALL
E WILL GIVE THE  TO THS WOULD B.
OUB EARL00s  MTHERE HAVE BN OR
BILLION.
WOULD HE RY
CONF?HAVE TO WAIT ANDEE.
>>NG ABOUT
IZYACHTS, IT SOUNDS
COMPCAS IN YOUR , YOU
DO IT,
ARE ON THE SUPER
BECAUSN WOULD BEON THAT, R
FASCINATING